i want to introduce dr chow so
he has a long and illustrious career
before he kind of got into cloud
computing but i you know the part i'll
focus on is when he
uh when he started
really on the the when that was just
getting started in 1999 when you were
brought back to oracle to launch and run
oracle on demand
and out of that experience as i
understand you wrote this book in 2004
called the end of software and in that
book
it's really one of the first works that
that talks about software as a service
which of course is now a household
kind of term today and in fact in that
you mentioned three
then startups that are now also
businesses that just about everyone
knows so vmware netsuite and salesforce
shortly after you wrote that book uh you
launched the class we'll be talking
about today the cloud computing class in
2005.
um and so right you know right on the
heels of that and as we were talking
about shortly after that in 2006 i think
just six months after that class
probably debuted
amazon launched some of the real
inaugural cloud services infrastructure
cloud services so
s3 and i think ec ec2 so the computing
instructions are so technical what i
thought you weren't technically i'm not
technical i have to do a little bit of
research so so you know really this
class is embedded and your work is
really you were at the forefront of it
and thinking about
writing about and and as a practitioner
and visionary for cloud computing and i
you know obviously you've done a lot of
things since then and in fact i should
note you were teaching with scpd far
before the cloud computing seminar so
you're teaching i believe computer
architecture and the electrical
engineering department
um so you have a long history there as
well kind of it's not and maybe that
wasn't the cloud but teaching online as
well
uh
and then most recently so there's a long
history here but in 2020 you
uh you launched a company that's using
the edge cloud to really transform
pediatric care and hopefully we can hear
a little bit more about that experience
yeah so it's we're really excited to
have you here today the opportunity to
talk about the class and use that as an
opportunity also to think about the
cloud more generally so
i think for those in the audience who
are like me non-technical it would be
great to get a definition to cloud
because i think often we just i just
think of as the internet until you
really you know dig down into it i know
they're not synonymous so what is the
cloud
so uh yeah well first of all pax thanks
for having me thanks for for doing this
we
we really uh this class is i think very
unique in the world and so getting the
word out for both uh kids that are here
at stanford as well as the wider
communities thank you for doing that
um so what is a cloud i mean
fundamentally if you if you start to
think about it in a different way
you would go that what the cloud is is
really a supplier
who builds software like an application
or maybe builds hardware like a server
says rather than you
have to manage
the security of it the availability the
performance
right the change in that software which
is where we all came from we used to
have to do that why don't i do that for
you
so i'll do that for you as salesforce
for crm applications i'll do that for
you
for storage and compute that's what
amazon's doing
so fundamentally it's a shift from the
old world where
and in corporate america i have whole
teams of people having to do this work
to manage the infrastructure manage the
applications
the suppliers now and obviously the
ability for a network which we have
today to perform was key to making all
this possible but
that clearly had happened by let's call
it the dawn of this which is really late
99 early 2000 so
the other point to make is that there's
there's two aspects one is what i said
which is
it's about the supplier doing that
the second part is
really the economic advantage of doing
that
because if you think about it in the old
world if i sent you a piece of software
well the way you manage it the way i
manage the way somebody else managed it
might be completely different and by the
way done by humans
right right
but if i standardize if i say no i'm
just gonna do it for this piece of
software
and i'm gonna upgrade it on tuesdays at
two o'clock or whatever
then i can i can progressively
standardize repeat and automate the
process
well if i automate it then all that
labor that used to be used to go manage
this
technology these applications this
infrastructure i can replace with
computers which by the way are a hell of
a lot cheaper right they operate pretty
much flawlessly compared to humans
and therefore in a great sense are
actually more secure than the world we
have come from
and that economic shift is the other big
thing that happened not only was
technology made available but also the
economics so
it really started
as you already kind of pointed out early
on with applications that's what we did
at oracle we tried to deliver the oracle
erp crm applications as a service
obviously salesforce
with crm
netsuite with erp all started to do this
in applications first
and then amazon really led the game over
in infrastructure by saying no not just
applications but compute and storage
and the economic thing they did the
business model shift they made which was
huge was oh by the way you can have this
computer for an hour
and i and then i'll give you can give it
back to me so the resource is just much
more flexible enormously more flexible
right
and so it removed me having to do any of
this which is why every startup on the
planet uses somebody's cloud
infrastructure right because why do i
want to go manage this
as well as the economic advantage of
being able to do this yeah one of the
interesting points so i i didn't mention
in in the
my bio of you is that you also have a
sort of a trilogy of books on cloud
computing that came out in i think 2015
somewhere around there um
and
you know in it what was really
interesting i you know sort of going
through it is is how much you emphasize
that business case and one thing that i
had no idea and that was very
interesting is
you were saying when you buy software
that's not the that's not where the cost
is going to come in it's it's you were
saying i think the number you're quoting
that could be totally wrong but it's
like four times the cost of the software
is what you'll be spending annually to
maintain it if you're if you're
maintaining it on premises which blew my
mind
good memory good memory yeah that's
that's so it's enormous so that that's
the business change the economic change
absolutely absolutely
and so uh and i think you also mentioned
as you mentioned now that kind of the
big the big innovation that amazon
introduced was again not necessarily the
technical side though there are
obviously technical challenges that they
had to address
but was the business model and so
if things got started in the early 2000s
in terms of applications in terms of the
infrastructure moving to the cloud
what's on the horizon now what have been
the interesting developments especially
coming off of
a few years where many of us were really
living in the cloud in terms of
everything we were doing was is being
held online
yes let me just highlight a couple of
things and and i like to split between
infrastructure and applications
think about this so on the
infrastructure side i mean amazon's
continued to innovate i mean the number
of services on top of the ec2 s3 is
immense it's in the hundreds right um
and i think one of the areas they have
been particularly interested in it's
kind of you know part of everybody's
conversation is the world of ai
and in particular right how does ai
really begin to help
programmers
you know it's a weird thing to think
about taking programmers out of the loop
and how do i use ai to do that
they're also helping people kind of
start to learn about this so
there's a project they have out there
called deep racer people i'll take a
look at it
it's really you get to go program an
autonomous virtual car
oh wow to try to begin you know because
i think we do and you know obviously
stanford's at the forefront of this but
across the world right a lack of
understanding of what capabilities this
type of technology has which really is
formed from the basics of cloud
computing
um if you spend any time in the world of
deep learning
you know that really to get more
accurate
uh predictions more accurate more
accuracy
you need two things you need more data
and you need more compute well guess
what getting more and more compute is
part of what cloud infrastructure so
amazon's pushing
pushing that um
i'll highlight uh another company
teradata in fact i was just at um i'm on
the board it was just at a new york
stock exchange event two days ago and
they just introduced at the database
level right the ability to have not only
data lakes but data warehouses what some
people call lake houses as
infrastructure as a service to now start
to provide higher level services not
just the computing storage but the
ability to do analytics on structured
and unstructured data so that that
that's a step many people are made
because analytics is huge in everybody's
business
um
another one just to highlight you know
one of the things uh i've been able to
do is i'm part of the alchemist
accelerator which is actually a little
bit of a stanford spin out because
robbie and i are all part of you know
kind of the community
but we had a number of great stories
just highlight one there's a company out
there called yoda scale
which is very early on in at alchemist
and what they're endeavoring to do is to
help people manage the cost because
the good news is it's easy to get this
stuff
the bad news is from the
cfo's perspective is well you know pax
do you really need that instance
so yoda scales using technology to help
do cost management of what is a
burgeoning amount of resource being used
you know by people like hulu or disney
or whatever right and
it has an interesting implication
on sustainability because
if you think about it in an information
age the smoke stack
is the computers right
they're generating all the carbon
so not only is a managing efficiency
cost wise but also you know from a
carbon perspective so that's kind of
i'll say a couple little highlights of
what's cool on the infrastructure side
if you move over to applications
i'll say
uh increasingly companies that
historically have operated on
have moved to delivering all their
applications as a cloud service
i'll highlight one blackbaud which many
people probably don't know but they are
a company that's dedicated to building
cloud applications for social good their
customers are people like save the
children i think stanford's a customer
because they started out really in
helping people do fundraising
they pretty much move their entire stack
in fact i think right now only like two
percent of their customers operate in
the old on-premises world the rest of
it's operating in the cloud world using
their applications as a cloud service
and azure
and amazon as the infrastructure right
uh and they're about to hit a billion
dollars in fact the plan is next year
they'll be a billion dollars as a
business right
uh i'll give you another one um
there's an interesting company again an
alchemist accelerator company called
umitza umnitsa has seen this
explosion in the use of you know whether
it's laptops cell phones cloud
infrastructure applications in the
enterprise
and is now saying hey mr or miss cio
why don't you have an application so you
can manage
that incredibly complex and remember
these days that technology is now in
people's houses right
and how do i manage the security how do
i manage off-boarding an employee all
the different things i have to think
about doing how do i use computers to go
do that
and that's just an example of there's so
many at this stage
you know apple what i call application
cloud services
spurred by the availability of
infrastructure cloud services that's
really interesting i i want we're going
to sort of dive into the class a little
bit but just a couple
follow-up quick follow-up on the
infrastructure side
do you see so you know again when i and
this is the non-technical lay person i
think of amazon microsoft and google as
the big infrastructure side providers
you mentioned ai is that creating i've
also heard that there's that's kind of
opening up a space for more niche
providers of those services that are
tailored specifically towards ai is that
is that kind of what you're saying with
the analytics there's an opportunity
competition is entering
in providing those kind of niche
storage and compute services that are
maybe around specific uh functions is
that a fair statement and if so can you
elaborate on that
yeah uh well let me make two comments
one i'd say the big boys meaning amazon
google azure are all
uh increasingly providing more
capabilities to deliver the ability to
train ai algorithms where there's a lot
of compute required
uh in fact that some people are aware of
there are specialized hunks of hardware
being built by guys like google to go do
this sort of thing so
it is not lost on them either that this
is not interesting
um i think in any industry as you
get bigger and bigger there is the
chance for specialization so it is
entirely possible and and this could be
specialization
by location because one of the things
that the big cloud you know
infrastructure cloud providers is really
they operate out of ten data centers in
the world
right not a hundred not a thousand there
are reasons why it might be better to be
closer to the source of the information
uh from communication point of view but
also increasingly i think in in the
world we're living in there's
increasingly walls going up that
you know because i've been working a lot
in health care there's increasingly
walls going up even between europe and
the united states like we're not sharing
right so this calls into question yes
we're going to have to start to move the
infrastructure perhaps to specialized
players perhaps to different kinds of
cloud service players uh as well that's
really interesting so i mean that's when
you think of the cloud you think of it's
kind of it just exists you know out
there on the in the in the cloud but in
fact it has this infrastructure and that
it sounds like that might even become
more important uh in some senses as the
world the political world sort of
changes yes yes uh great well so
you know with that i want to learn more
what we're going to be doing
you know this this year in the cloud
computing class but what
so back in 2005 what
what why did you start cs309a is the uh
the stanford number the cloud computing
seminar yeah what compelled you to do
that um yeah could you tell us a little
bit about that yeah so um as you
indicate in the opening comments i
i i taught core computer architecture as
uh kind of as a hobby i
i'd leave work come to campus teach
class it was kind of fun you know i just
i taught a graduate seminar or
class of hobby so yeah well i could tell
the whole story about how that happened
but anyway i i was doing that and uh so
i taught for 15 years actually every
other quarter you know core curriculum
what in those days was called cs110 and
w181 for old-timers
and so
there came a day where i actually had to
fly to bali to do a sales kickoff
meeting and get back in 36 hours to
teach class
and i was going this is getting to be a
little ridiculous so i gave myself a
sabbatical
a leave of absence
so uh as you said i was at oracle and i
decided at some point you know i was
going to leave and so i was hanging
around
campus and for those of you guys in
computer science who know claire steger
claire and i yeah know each other for
lots of years obviously and so claire is
like well why don't you come back and
teach i was like that's a lot of work he
said well you could do a seminar class
right
and so i started thinking about the fact
that and you know because i was on
campus some of the time people would say
you know where's the computer science
department you know and uh
you know over time you go well you point
to the gate spell but i was starting to
think about why do i point to the gates
building why am i not pointing to the
geology and the physics and the
sociology and the psychology business
buildings why why do i not think that
right and so it it made me think a lot
about well how is it that we get the
wider population
uh
our students in medicine law right the
liberal arts to really being in to
appreciate what this technology could do
to reshape
any of these areas right
and so
obviously because i've been around here
for a while you know i i knew a lot of
people and
i said well why don't i put together a
class where i do the first and last
lecture
and by the way they're probably pretty
identical back to not working too hard
and in between i would have eight guest
lectures
and all my guest lectures would be ceos
of public companies
to come and tell their story in essence
which obviously i'm not trying to get
down to how do you provision an ec2
instance right
but why and how were they gonna where
are they using this technology to begin
to bring a wider group of people into
this so we very much campaign in fact i
just sent a bunch of emails out to my
friends in the law school we have had a
good number of kids out of the law
school because i i say look
the intersection between the law and
computer science software ai is honest
and you know
i would claim we can easily today see
how stupid the laws are because nobody
really understands the technology
so is it going to be that we teach all
of our computer science kids about the
law right or
do we teach the law students maybe not
the you know i don't care if you could
be a python programmer but can you
understand the concepts and why the
economics et cetera so that we make more
informed decisions
in the law in medicine in the liberal
across the board and that's
that was kind of my mission and
you know uh over time i learned that
people were not um
offended to be asked to deliver a guest
lecture at stanford so some of the kids
now call the class uh people tim wants
to listen to you
and so that's interesting so it's not
primarily you know one thing that is
interesting in terms of our portfolio is
we have a lot of seminars but they're
highly technical so it's it's
researchers nai coming in and talking
about the latest algorithm or the latest
you know
way to verify uh you know a neural
network or something like that this is
not as technical this is more
focused on the business side of a very
specific technology as well
can you talk a little bit more about you
know your student body and you know what
your students are getting what are your
computer science students getting out of
it versus what are your say law or
business students getting out of it is
it the same thing i mean what
what are they bringing that's unique or
what are they getting out of it that's
unique in the way this classes yeah well
um
you know you'll you may appreciate this
one of the things
i i we've all i think all the kids i
call them the kids
all the kids i've taken i think they do
get a lot out of it so what do they get
out of it right i think
on the one hand um
i have a requirement to get it's a one
credit class
so i have a requirement one of the
requirements is
uh that they ask a question because i
start out the class the same way i go
you know the mark of a great student is
not measured by what you know
but by the questions you ask so i want
you to learn to ask good questions and
so just as practice right before every
lecture shows up i have a shared
spreadsheet
and there's pax's name and pax's
question for ragu from vmware
and i think that helps right because
then they get a little bit deeper into
but what the heck does vmware do or get
lab i mean for some people they already
know but a lot of people don't
so they begin to develop an appreciation
because i always tell the lecturers you
know unless you're google or facebook
nobody knows what you do including
general electric by the way so
you know i think that gets them a little
deeper into the world uh one
i think the second thing that i i hope
they register out of it is
that you know
all ceos are not college dropouts who
wear hoodies
right i mean it is a vast uh different
profiles of what you see there right
and their stories
are across the spectrum right in fact
one of the things i always do
when the lecturer shows up and i say to
him hey
i want you to tell me a story which you
would not know about you from the
internet
and so i've got this would be a great i
should have asked you that question
by the way now i feel like i'm being
graded if my questions aren't good
you're doing
and so you know uh just a simple example
martin richenhagen who was the ceo of
adco one of the largest agricultural
equipment manufacturing united states
uh actually asked his board if he could
coach the german equestrian team in the
olympics
like who the heck would have been
okay right uh we've had uh george john
this is great one of the things i do
is every year i look to see
what companies just went public right
along with my kind of standing list
and uh that year rocket fuel had gone
public and so i'm like okay i just
by this time i learned i could just send
email in so i said oh hi
their ceo's george john hey george you
know would you like to come and do a
lecture
and so i get a reply back oh yeah tim
i'd be interested
p.s
i was your student
a few years ago
and i went really
so we met and um
for those of you who had taken this
class one of the things we would uh have
the students do was build a small
multitasking kernel so this is for the
this is for my computer architecture
class along right we go back in time
and uh
george says yeah he he must have taken
the class in the spring
because he went home for summer vacation
he was sleeping in
he said yeah my my mom woke me up and
said what you you're so lazy why are you
still sleeping in he goes mom you don't
understand i just wrote a multi-testing
curve
so we've had this range right phd
students from stanford people who do
equestria and i think that helps
the kids see the range of what's
possible out there and not imprint on
one particular pattern
and as a result we've had quite a few i
mean i'll just hit one that's kind of
fun uh there's a team out of uh the
class 2019
that uh launched a new company called
nooks oh we're familiar yeah we know you
should know nux and that's daniel and a
bunch of those guys that were in that
class
who decided to go do that and you know
build kind of a very new we'll call a
collaboration environment particularly
focused these days in the sales world
but that's just an example of i think
you know whether the class was the
reason but i think i've heard this from
a number of them that it has inspired
them pushed them made them think what
was possible
rather than what i do believe a lot of
people walk into stanford particularly
and think well [ __ ] if i didn't you know
write a multitasking colonel when i was
12 years old i got no business in this
which is you know patently not true so
yeah uh that that's really yeah we know
nook i mean it was
because they that must have launched
just before or just during the the
pandemic so it was oh yeah something
they were rolling out in a lot of uh
classes here just as a kind of
alternative way to do office hours
you know grading
grading parties watch parties so that's
interesting that's it i didn't realize
that started as a team in your class
that's good to know yeah um well so
what's on you know in in that's a great
segue because uh you know we're talking
you're two last time you ran this class
was in 2019 was 2019 i think one of the
last speakers was the the ceo of zoom at
the time so again a very prescient or
you know
serendipitous
invitee in this in this course uh it's
been on hold for two years because the
pandemic now it's coming back uh so what
what is what's on offer for the class
this year and
you know has that changed at all in the
last two years in terms of how you're
thinking about the invitations how did
the last two years influence who you're
thinking about inviting this year yeah
uh but just to tell a small story since
you brought up eric eric rand was
actually i went back and looked i think
it was the last lecture of that year of
19.
and one of the things just to make a
comment
because i think a lot of people think
about oh well the reason people do
startup whatever started companies to
make millions of dollars and whatnot
which obviously eric's done well but he
talked a lot about he he was actually at
the original webex
and and was there for a lot of years and
he said the reason i started zoom was
you know the customers we had just were
not happy
and i knew we could we could make them
happy and
it's just fascinating that that
motivation
resulted in today a you know a noun of
urban and adverse right yeah right um so
so just as that quick on on eric so uh
uh yeah so who's coming this year
we always i think our lineups are pretty
all-star
so remember i said i i wanted to get to
law school and you know et cetera so um
i happen to do a
a talk for
morgan lewis which is actually the
fourth largest law firm in the world
and by
that i met jamie mccoon who's their
uh firm chair and so i asked jamie to
come and speak so one of our speakers
this year is actually the chairman of
the fourth largest law firm in in the
world
now that that's is that is is that a
departure from your usual list is this
someone who's not going to talk about
the business but you know it's not
themselves in a business that's
delivering a cloud app or a cloud
infrastructure true and
to your question yes
she's as far off as i've gotten because
they
are well the law does consume cloud
services but obviously one of the things
that i
invited her for is because we know that
the law
privacy etc is starting to impact how we
use technology whether on the consumer
side or on the enterprise side so that's
really her but you know over time i
branched out
i got particularly interested in the
so-called internet of things
which is how i ended up having the uh
the chair of
excuse me the ceo adco which is the
fourth largest uh excuse me one of the
largest agricultural equipment
manufacturers
which by the way led to and just as a
teaser i i i
i have been inviting
there's a lady who is the ceo of tafe
which is the largest agriculture
equipment manufacturer in india and i've
had a deliberate move to try to get ceos
of public companies who are women
to come and do my class the list is not
enormous right in fact i had patty pope
a couple years ago she was ceo cms
energy which is michigan's energy
company
very interestingly she started out her
talk which is why i talk about kids
learn a lot of different things she got
up there and said you know
people ask me
how work-life balance works i suppose
they ask me that because i'm a woman
and she goes i think it's the wrong
question
and she proceeds to go into which i have
introduced people there's a whole
japanese philosophy called ikigai and
she proceeded to do like a 10 minute
dissertation on ikigai which is
extremely cool she talked a lot about
energy at the end i was talking to her i
said you know patty could you come to to
come to pg e
and help us out well damn diff
like nine months ago she is new the new
ceo of pg e wow okay well
so anyway so we uh jamie which is a
little
scope um on the infrastructure front uh
ragu who's the ceo of vmware vmware
really is a cornerstone of what people
refer to as private cloud computing
so it's really cool that he's able to be
here
um
the other one is sid who's the ceo of
get lab get it every all the cs kids
know what the hell get lab is but get is
really the major repository for code
so if you are a software developer or
you're using software
your
your software is on their software and
that is
infrastructure for building other things
right so is this github is it the same
or
hub
yeah so hub got bought by microsoft and
lab is
okay there you go a lot of the guys who
yeah okay so they're two
but it's in principle the same thing
it is providing similar services the
other interesting thing about uh get
which i'm gonna have sid talk about is
they very early on talked about they
they wanted to build a decentralized
business this is prior to covet
so there is no corporate headquarters
i mean from day one which is fascinating
and the things that they have had to do
in order to make that work i'm
he's going to talk about i'm enormously
fascinated with so we'll get a lesson on
how to yeah how to build a decentralized
uh business yeah exactly that's
interesting uh couch base i didn't want
to forget matt cain's coming for couch
base
couchbase is a specialized
open source database software so that's
going to be cool
when we move over to applications
i'm having the ceo of samsara come
samsara
this internet of things area which which
is really if you look at it most of
technology we've built up until now
services the financial service world
uh the media world you know netflix
whatever and the telco world that's
dominates the
spend
which is by the way a third of the
global gdp
two-thirds of the global gdp
is everything else
which we will call manufacturing but is
actually automotive healthcare trucking
transportation
agriculture you know all these other
industries which as you and i were
talking very early on
these industries because they touch the
physical world move less
quickly even though they are enormous
so while the internet of things and i'm
not talking about smart toasters i'm
talking about enterprise
has
been projected as being trillions and
trillions of dollars
there's been no great liquidity event no
great startup that has come out of it
even though a lot of money's been thrown
at it samsara stands unique in that so
they they went public last year and i'm
really excited to have him uh come and
talk and really how did they navigate
this is going to be very interesting
right
uh which then gets to
uh as we said we talk about things and
and i've been interested in the
healthcare space um the ceo
of illumina is coming so for those
people in the world of genetics and uh
biomedical research they all know
illumina is because lumino is really
kind of the you know the 100 000
pound gorilla in the gene sequencing
world and the implications of that
uh on everything in health care is
enormous that's going to be very cool
and then i'm having the chairman and ceo
of johnson johnson who is number 26 in
the fortune 500. so i like to have a
range from you know
relatively young companies to you know
very mature companies
and so we'll have that whole
during this this quarter
that's fantastic i see we're getting
some questions and i think they're
they're relevant to kind of the
direction you're already taking in terms
of your speaker list yeah we talked a
little bit about what's on the horizon
on the cloud
and we're getting questions you know
what's next what are the big
technologies what are going to be the
big shifts do you see you said that
internet of things has been this big
promise for a while
and it sounds like um
it's been slower to to kind of really
realize that promise do you still see
internet of things
as the next big thing in terms of cloud
computing or just as a technology
and what do you anticipate its impact to
be
yeah i think
it's
maybe at a macro level the comment i
said look we've all been pretty good at
the stuff that is the not physical world
you know retake right obviously
financial services right where the
change is really a change in an app
that's all that happens right
but the the change in the physical world
which we all do live in
is where there is enormous potential
right um
how do we do precision agriculture
right to be able to grow more food
using less pesticides and less water
which is both more sustainable and
healthier
you know if i can now which people are
working on this you know i can now map a
piece of soil
down to a square meter
and know the boron level and make a
choice based on that
which the technology is arriving to do
all this stuff the implications on the
world
right that we live in
are enormous i i think
you know
while these are all hard and i'm
like said spending a lot of time in
health care
they're all hard for a whole variety of
reasons the promise of what they can do
into the future is enormous so for those
who are patient
and you know yeah i know if you want to
do a startup in two years later sell to
google don't do this
don't do this but if you really are
committed and i met plenty of people
committed to different areas here
you know i think what what technology is
capable of today and what it will be
capable over the next
three four five years is just it's crazy
i mean i'll i'll just give you one
example because i'm spending time in
healthcare
there's a condition
uh in uh that happens in kids
uh where they get uh something called
focal cortical dysplasia called fcd okay
basically and this is my obviously i
have no medical background uh the
neurons are too close together in your
brain
so if you can detect this which can be
done with mri scans and ai technology
you actually can go in and they call it
resect which i observe it as cut it a
little bit apart
and the kid is cured for life there's a
kid in florida right now who's had
epileptic fits two times a day
from the age of 18 months to 12 years
old
they believe they figured it out finally
they've given him drugs they wanted to
put in implants and all this stuff they
think that this is what it is if it is
he's cured for life now think about
the implications of us being able to do
that for any kid on the planet
and what's the barrier to that right now
why why you know obviously not everyone
maybe has an mri but if you have an mri
in europe versus florida why why can't
they do that right now
um
it goes back to uh a couple things one
uh i made mention that uh
basically all the deep learning work um
neural network work is all based on the
idea that i can feed enough data to
these things to be able to train them
uh first of all
obviously that condition does not happen
all the time
so you need to be able to aggregate data
from many different locations and this
conversation of equity and diversity in
a.i is there which is
you know let's not train it on a bunch
of old white guys
right and then wonder why it doesn't
work for other people
so one of the challenges how do i get to
it how do i get to all of this right
and then i think a second challenge is
okay how do i bring this together teams
which is the tricky part of both
ai knowledgeable people and medical
knowledgeable people to be able to build
these applications um i think that's the
other big challenge we face but
you know that's we can get there this is
not right i'm sure the law factors in
there as well especially in sharing
medical data oh no no believe me the
whole world of privacy preservation
which is why i've become enormously
interested in federated learning as a
technology
yes
yes very interesting that's really uh
that's really interesting so that that's
you know
one thing i hear you saying is that as
especially as as the cloud gets bigger
and we can share more data these kinds
of rare events
uh
we'll have just more data if it happens
once in florida and then once in canada
and once in brazil there's no way you
can
there's no information sharing you have
no
central data source but as you can bring
those together you can start
understanding and diagnosing those kinds
of issues yeah that's really uh
that's interesting uh you know you had
mentioned earlier and this is maybe
another um
this is another uh
thing on the horizon or something that
that's being talked about a lot now is
you had mentioned
uh
sustainability in the context of as you
said your carbon footprint now isn't
smoke stacks it's your it's your data
centers
can you elaborate a little bit more on
that and what you see the future of
sustainability in cloud computing and
how it can help address that or how it
might exacerbate it
yeah let me let me take that and take
you down two paths okay
so one is uh
purely the uh for those people out there
who follow the world of investment
there's a whole thrust referred to as
esg
environment
social governance and it's largely
driven by the investment community so if
you're sitting in a board room which i
said in a couple of them it is a topic
so over on the environmental side um
which is really the carbon question
just to let the listeners think about it
today a server and a human
are roughly equivalent and how much
carbon we generate okay
yeah it's kind of curious to think about
that so now the question becomes if i'm
a company
what is my employee to server ratio
right because if i if i have very
low ratio meaning
yeah i've got you know a million
employees and i have two servers who the
hell cares you know drive your suvs to
work it doesn't really matter it's not
the smoke stack but if it's the opposite
meaning for every employee i have 10
servers then obviously
my servers are the source of my carbon
footprint
now what you will see is that the ratio
of companies which are not the new
generation companies
is 10 times different than the ratio of
the next generation
purely information economies facebook's
the googles the pinterest all of these
guys right
and so when you're over there which is
why there has been interest i i know
amazon's been working in this area right
in reducing their carbon footprint by
virtue of making their servers run on
because obviously
the servers are running the where's the
carbon coming from the carbon's coming
from the electricity
right so if i've got coal-fired plants
yeah that's big carbon footprint and by
the way if you get to be a student of
this you'll realize different regions of
the united states even have different
carbon footprints or alter their power
but if i can run on a hydro or if i can
run on wind right then obviously my
electricity is carbon so a great deal of
interest
there to moving more and more to
renewables as the
source of the electricity to reduce the
carbon footprint given i'm an
information
focused company
like the ones that we all know about are
now do you think there's there's a
is there a potential kind of challenge
there if my servers are actually amazon
servers then you know my server count to
poi account could be very low but i'm
using a lot of storage and compute
capacity but it's it's essentially being
outsourced to amazon and you in time or
maybe even now what you should be doing
is you should be asking yourself what is
the carbon footprint of the amazon
servers i'm using
and you can compute this so i made
comment about yoda scales work in cost
management is also you could translate
that quite quickly because you go well i
can know how many servers are they big
ones are they little ones am i running
24 hours or two hours
and you could compute right what is the
carbon footprint of your usage of that
amazon service
right and is
you know how big is that so that's part
of the next step is
you know i think it's inevitable given
we all are moving to more
information-based uh systems
uh i'll just make a little point um the
s part the societal part
i think i i i've been doing a little
study of this area most of it today is
really about what is the corporation's
responsibility from a diversity equity
and inclusion so
you know how many women do i have in the
workforce how many black people haven't
worked for which is all great but it's
all
internally focused
the question i think in front of us is
what is
what is the societal responsibility of
corporations outside of the corporation
right what is their responsibility to
global health care
what is their responsibility to global
education
i think these are questions that we're
all going to start to ask or we should
be asking right which all have
implications on what are you going to do
to impact global health care to impact
global education
interesting okay uh well that's good and
hopefully some of your your guests will
be talking about we're touching oh
you know yeah um
we're
reaching near the end and we do have a
couple more questions i i'm going to
choose one one more kind of on the
horizon
just because it's another buzzword
that's out there right now good can you
talk a little bit about the metaverse in
the cloud what do you see here now i
know that's very much within the you
know the the so you were talking about
the
you know uh media you know the netflix
of the world is already one of the big
players or big things that are being
delivered over the cloud
is the metaverse a new thing in your
opinion is this what where is that in in
your thinking
yeah well
i mean i don't you know what is the
metaverse i guess is the other big
question yeah
well i think
well we all let's try it this way i
think we all are looking at we all
continue to look at
different ways in which you interface
with this technology right today
it's largely the keyboard
uh right and we look at a screen uh
we're increasingly talking so talking is
a way
but obviously a whether it's a what
people will call an augmented
reality view of the world meaning i i
can put glasses on where i can see some
things that are coming from computers
and some things that are living in the
real world which do have implications on
things like
you know manufacturing uh construction
all these things where i could i would
benefit from that
or is it what people call virtual
reality which is you totally enclose the
headset et cetera obviously this is you
know gaming has clearly been over here
etc
um you know people because
because i've been doing work in the
physical world there are people working
in all of this you know whether it's
healthcare construction etc
uh
you could think of it as provide a
better experience a deeper richer
experience right to what you're doing
augmented by computers or replaced by
computers
you know i think it's just an
inevitability that we will get there
some of it today is bound by cost some
of it's bound by power some of it's
bound by you know writing the right
software to go do this and
i think each step of the way different
parts of the industry are
are pioneering this and
you know staring at a screen and
touching a keyboard 20 years from now
might look like an anachronism
interesting um
i mean we see wow we just got quite a
few questions uh
uh right off of that uh that question
yeah anything so you know
i guess the last thing i want to circle
back to the class a little bit and and
so we've talked about the class talk
about your history now talking a little
bit about what's on the horizon
and and also what's happening in this
class anything in particular that you're
excited about in this class what are you
know you mentioned that this is
some people call this class people that
tim wants to talk to so what are some of
the things that you're really excited
about asking and learning about you
already mentioned a few but anything
else you'd want to mention that you're
really excited about to learn or ask in
this upcoming cohort of speakers i will
tell you what i what i always walk away
learning from these classes is the
unexpected part
because i ask all the speakers i
basically just tell them there's three
things i want you to do number one i
want you to tell me about what you do
because like i said unless you're
facebook or google yeah nobody knows
number two how does cloud computing ai
5g
iot impact your business what has it
done what it how has it impacted it and
then finally what do you think whether
it's for your company or for your
industry
how will this impact your industry in
the future
and then the last thing i say is look
you've got 100 200
bright young minds sitting out there
what would you like to tell them yeah
and i think
which i i encourage them to do this
because this is for them i always say is
a very unique environment
this is not employees this is not
investors this is not customers none of
that right
and so i think and and you know they're
inspired a little bit about the give
back idea so
i think the things that they share their
life experiences the things that they
did
you know the mistakes that they made
whatever
it's just totally fascinating and i
could spend an hour telling you all
those stories
of the things that you learn from the
stories that they tell which are
completely unscripted it's just part of
how they
get up there and talk and also part of
how i try to structure the class
right i tell them look
every kid has asked a question so they
have questions
now the very first class i usually have
to kind of go you know
but by class two they're getting pretty
good and so
that environment stimulates right i
think the type of conversation that
happens
and the type of knowledge that's
transmitted
which is
to me way beyond
their company or their products or even
technology and do you think uh is that
what the students are also getting out
of it so i i asked that because
you know when we were advertising this
we got just a lot of people who saw us
posting and we're going to be talking
with dr timothy oh that's that's the
best class i took at stanford that was
my favorite class we never get that with
our other you know our other
webinar advertisements so
we were talking what what is it about
this class you know what is it that's so
exciting for students so is that is do
you think it's that element of the
unexpected what are the aha moments for
your students uh
what do you think there are those aha
moments that they're taking away you
know what i think is my theory of what
happens
this class if you're a freshman which i
encourage them to come and take it
it is not until six years later that
they go oh
so i think it's that you know because of
the nature of who is up there talking
how they speak
what they the stories they tell
that as time evolves they
the student
hears that story in their head it
becomes part of how they think about
things right which i think is very
powerful uh we had just a short plug for
the the dci group you're probably aware
of this right a distinguished career
these guys found my class like i think
the first year they did the program
right so i'm sitting down look at it out
in the classroom and i see a bunch of
old people
okay what the hell are you doing here
right
but
they clearly get this i mean day one
they're like can i come back i'm gonna
be back here right
because they know
the value of what is being said there
how it's being said who is saying it
right
uh and that's synthesis which i could
never go one two three four five i think
that's the power of this class and the
unique i mean it's enormously there's
nothing
like this anywhere in the world i like
that idea so the aha moments coming that
they're they're saying that was the
greatest class because they're like now
i realized that
five years later
but but i also what i thought was a
really interesting point there is is
that
and i think this is something to pull
out of it is how much narrative plays in
the way that the
the
uh speakers are presenting to the
students it's not a formal presentation
of here's you know here's how you create
a micro multitask kernel processor or
something like that it's not it's not
that it's it's personal stories it's
it's business stories and those stories
um can stay with you in the way maybe
technical information or uh you know uh
statistics don't necessarily stay with
you oh yeah and who the storyteller is
yeah right yeah that's that's that's
fantastic well thank you so much for
joining us today i want to remind
everyone if you're interested in taking
the class even if you're not a stanford
student you can do that you can see a
button right there on your console you
can click on it find out more
information about the class if you
happen to be joining us and you are a
stanford student we also encourage you
to enroll through access i think
enrollment starts on september 1st for
uh for stanford students it's already
started if you're
someone in the community a professional
who's interested in taking the class um
and we hopefully maybe we'll have dr
chow back again in the future to talk
more about cloud computing in his class
um thank you again it's really wonderful
conversation yeah thanks for having me
pax yeah i encourage you all the
stanford kids go tell your friends and
neighbors about it i mean you know i i'm
always stunned because on the very first
day i always go how do you know about
the class
and it's the most mundane answers like i
found in course catalog i'm going god
you know modern technology we have no
better way but the course catalog's
online now yeah
yeah
well
yes please take the class and uh and
again as i said a recording of this
session will be made available in about
a week so if you miss some of it
it'll be available it'll be available
soon thank you all for joining us thank
you for your questions i'm sorry we
didn't get to all of them but they were
they were fantastic
you